good morning belief nation today's
message is fail learn and move forward
failure is a part of the learning
process right what's the risk of failure
what you'll be embarrassed or risk of
how do you distinguish failure from
learning uh in your whole life you know
failure implies that it stopped that the
game stops alright if it's part of a
you're failing and then you learn then
that learning is part of the moving
forward right so that is what the
process is like fail learn move forward
and constantly do that because you're
cutting edge you're going where people
haven't been before an inventiveness
that's exciting to those people so
that's a different kind of approach to
life right it's a different way of being
it blows my mind how many entrepreneurs
are still afraid of failure you have to
understand that you fail your way to
success whenever you try anything new
you're gonna fail at it and most people
are so afraid to fail that they don't
even try and that's the biggest failure
of all the only way that it's gonna be a
failure is if you don't learn from it
and move forward you just take those
steps back you don't think how can I
become better how can I do it better the
next time and move forward towards your
goal whenever you learn anything the
first time you suck at it right we've
talked about this a lot on the channel
you fail you fail you fail every time
you fail a little bit less a little bit
less severely and you get better and
better and better and better and better
until you eventually make it nobody ever
hits it on the first try so be
comfortable with failure understand that
it's going to happen it's not pleasant
it's not happy but you can't totally
avoid it just accept that if you take
these small failures don't go on and
make a huge big failure start these
small failures build your way up and
eventually become successful so my
question the day for you today is I want
to know what you're gonna try today what
are you going to try today that's
different that there's a risk of
but it's a small task that you will try
and implement today in your business
leave it in the comments below I'm
curious to see what you're gonna do
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day he teams to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of ENSO